christophe noda fin dans cet extrait de
la tragédie du roi christophe la femme
du monarque met en garde un homme qui
veut tout maîtriser tout contrôler dans
son royaume
les femmes ont souvent eu un rôle d'ange
gardien dans les pièces d'aimé césaire
c'est cet aspect qui aujourd'hui prête
encore à débat kelly pedneault voulait
mettre en lumière sur les planches de ce
théâtre de fort de france il ya
certaines personnes qui pensent que dans
le théâtre de césaire il n'a pas accordé
suffisamment importante
donc j'avais à coeur de montrer que
c'est pas fondées que les femmes ont un
rôle très important dans le théâtre
ceyzérieu et et que c'est
malheureusement les héros qui sont sous
eau prix des fables au cours de cette
soirée hommage au poète quatre extraits
de pièces ont été abritées par les
stagiaires de l'atelier théâtre du
sermac que diriger les penno même si les
oeuvres de lutter et à une attention
particulière les comédiens se prête tout
de même au jeu des fois quand ne
comprend pas un mot b
thoune ou deux phrases et tout ça donc
on demande des explications des élèves
et puis il nous donne pour la phrase le
texte est un sens le travail d'une amie
concentré dans quatre pièces une saison
au congo et les chiens se taisaient une
tempête et la tragédie du roi christophe
quelque part dans la nuit le cas
notamment les plus belles oeuvres de
théâtre du chantre de la négritude
interprété dans les murs de son ancienne
mairie une soirée intitulée hommage à
papa césaire à laquelle les passionnés
peuvent assister gratuitement